Big fight with GSP.
Oh yeah.
That's,
that's why that took place because you had that belt.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I mean joint fight,
George beat me fair and square that night.
But uh,
there was a lot going on going into that camp that,
uh,
the final week.
And again,
I never said anything at the time because God blessed George and,
and he's a great guy and I respect the hell out of George.
I really do.
How can you not,
you know,
I mean,
I know I talked all that shit leading into the five,
but that was just me having a laugh,
you know?
I was literally having fun with it.
You know?
No ill will towards yours seem like you're enjoying it.
Just having fun,
just busting balls.
You know what I mean?
I think George is incredible.
I think George is the consummate professional.
He's a inspiration to all the Sperry martial artists out there.
If there's one man you can model your career on the way Twain's the way he looks
after his body,
the way cross trains judge Jpa will be that man,
you know,
he's an inspiration to myself,
so,
uh,
nothing but the greatest of respect.
But people as we said at the star of the show that doesn't sell.
People don't want to see that.
So I'll play the bad guy.
I've been portrayed as the bad guy my entire career,
you know,
by the UFC,
the editing,
you know,
I've fallen foul to some creative editing.
I've fallen foul to my own mouth as well at times.
So,
you know,
come on.
You know,
I'm my own worst enemy as well.
But um,
the week before the phone,
yeah,
we,
before the fight,
uh,
that the best training camp and my life,
you know,
uh,
sounds braggy,
but knocking out multiple sparring partners,
not on purpose.
It just felt incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
Final sparring session,
we had my protein and they'd flown in for a photo shoot or someone else there
for a photo shoot.
The Gym's absolutely packed.
And we got some guys in their aspiring me and um,
you know,
everybody wants to be the guy,
the,
the guests to take down or whatever or get to submission on the guide.
That's,
you know,
that's how it is.
That's why I don't like go into too many MMA gyms when I was fine because every
time you walk in you have a target on your back.
Anyway,
it was the final round.
We don't five rounds,
it was the Friday before the fight and this guy shoots in,
shoot a double leg wounds.
We all the way across the octagon,
like his life depended on,
it,
depended on it,
picked me up,
slammed me down and his shoulders went,
Gosh,
Ryan to my ribs.
And I felt it instantly.
Just all the cartilage is tor completely.
And uh,
I just started swearing and screaming,
fuck fucking,
you know,
cause I knew,
I knew I went a saw a doctor and Warner and a,
yeah,
it wasn't good.
So I was,
I got treatment every day and I was having Nice on me and all that type of
stuff.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it wasn't working.
So
what we came up with,
whichever,
with his plan,
it was going to inject myself with lighter came before the fight cause it,
cause it will not,
but the problem is the area where it was was,
uh,
you,
you can pierce along to where I have to go in.
You,
you could piss a lot of bleed to death because he turned on yet.
So I've got this dark and I was going to add the needle.
I had the lighter cane and I was going to fucking go in and sneak into the
toilet and facetime the doctor.
And he was like,
okay.
And anyway,
the whole thing just to do on top of it was it was bullshit.
I was like,
fuck this,
this is the stupidest plan ever.
Bollix to it.
I'll fire with the sole rib.
A bit of Adrenalin and you're not,
I've got to feel it anyway,
which I didn't under night,
you know.
But people said,
oh,
you didn't put yourself in there,
you weren't moving too much.
It's like,
yeah,
no shit.
I could've moved.
But,
eh,
but as I say,
Hey,
all credit to George,
God bless him.
He did great.
Did you,
there was a sparring partner that you had sparked with regularly now I,
it came Ed Dana.
I'm a singer.
Great Guy.
Just came in from England for the last couple of weeks.
So as dean,
who took you down?
Yeah,
Dean.
Very well.
Do you know dean?
Yeah.
Fucking day in the Prager.
What the fuck dude?
Yeah,
no,
he's a great guy.
Deans are so he's great.
Yeah,
he's great.
You know,
it's the way it goes.
You're training and uh,
yeah.
What are you gonna do?
So many fights.
It went,
that was half filled Los Angeles when you're supposed to fight McGregor,
like last,
the last sparring kicks and elbows and breaks his foot.
Oh.
So that's why [inaudible] came in.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's happened to so many guys.
Such a fine line because,
because you feel good,
you trained your heart,
you feel great and you think,
ah,
like you coach will say,
okay,
let's call it there guys.
We're good.
Call in there.
And you're like,
I dunno.
I feel good.
Come on,
let's get one good one is because sometimes I normally train a spa Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday.
And if it's the Wednesday,
spire goes really well.
You like less end it there because you want to end on a really good spar.
You know what I mean?
Because you feel like a world champion,
you feel great.
You know,
I,
you remember how you handled all your sparring partners and,
and whatever good shots you landed and you didn't really take any damage.
That's a great,
that's great momentum to go into the fight with.
And you don't know if you have another spine surgeon is going to go like that.
Right.
You know?
Or you might be tired,
you might be wind down,
those guys might be on their game that day.
And if you get a Tufts by session,
well then you want to do one more because you can't go into a fight after
getting your ass kicked and aspiring session.
You know what I mean?
That's not good Karma or energy to go in there with.
Um,
so it's always a weird one to fine.
It's fine balancing gags.
But,
uh,
yeah,
there you go.